[Música]
el trabajo híbrido está muerto
qué fácil es matar una de las tendencias
más importantes del último año verdad un
título y listo muerto buenas tardes soy
arquitecto y diseñador y dedicó gran
parte de mi vida profesional a
replantear uno de los espacios donde
muchos pasamos la mayor parte de nuestro
tiempo
en pocas palabras soy diseñador de
oficinas y como muchos de ustedes la
pandemia- me obligó a tener que
abandonar mi espacio físico en una
oficina y tener que trabajar desde la
casa todos los días fue una experiencia
muy particular o sea un diseñador de
oficinas diseñando oficinas desde la
casa como que suena raro verdad pero es
que así fue
y de hecho el tener que trabajar desde
la casa como a muchos de ustedes me tomó
por sorpresa completamente
sinceramente era algo a lo que yo no
estaba acostumbrado a hacer ni tampoco
jamás pensé tener que acostumbrarme
sin embargo empezaron a pasar los días y
también empecé a notar ciertas cosas que
me gustaban como por ejemplo no más
presas para llegar a la oficina por ende
más tiempo libre incluso llegué a pensar
que mi vida al fin tenía ese balance con
el que siempre había soñado
pero seguían pasando los meses y algo no
empezaba a sonar también ese confort de
estar desde la casa empezábamos bien a
sentirse como cierta incomodidad
usted cuántos de ustedes no se sienten
identificados con esa foto una fuerza
que me da mucha vergüenza haberla puesto
la verdad pero es que es una foto muy
real miles de llamadas por zoom en
pantalones de pijama desórdenes de
horario y muchísimo trabajo acumulado en
las noches
lamentablemente eso se empezó a volver
la norma para mí
al pasar alejado de mí de mi equipo de
trabajo empecé también a enfrentarme una
pregunta muy difícil no solo como
diseñador de espacios de trabajo sino
también como un colaborador más dentro
de una organización cómo podía
permanecer conectado no solo
laboralmente sino emocionalmente a mi
trabajo y a mi equipo
todos los días me levantaba con gran
incertidumbre y ahora que para qué sirve
lo que yo hago y es que se escuchaba que
las empresas están reduciendo su espacio
físico y era cierto durante la pandemia
muchas empresas optaron por reducir su
espacio físico y moverse a un modelo
virtual
sin embargo los datos demuestran que no
fue la norma para todos y que de hecho
el 44% de las empresas más innovadoras y
mejor calificadas a nivel mundial en
realidad están incrementando su huella
inmobiliaria esto durante la pandemia
los datos también nos muestran que el 53
por ciento de los colaboradores de
dichas empresas en realidad prefieren ir
a la oficina para trabajar en cosas que
tengan que ver con la ideación y la
creatividad
y ustedes se preguntarán qué es esto sea
como es posible hoy en día cuando el el
trabajo híbrido es cada vez más común y
si el modelo está siendo aplicado cada
vez más pero es que no es nada nuevo y
estas empresas innovadoras lo vienen
haciendo desde hace años y con gran
éxito sin embargo no fue hasta que nos
enfrentamos a su implementación masiva y
forzada que nos empezamos a enfrentarnos
solo a sus grandes virtudes sino también
a sus grandes retos y nos dimos cuenta
que definitivamente una sola receta no
aplica para todos
a ver bueno tal vez con el título fue un
poco duro y un poco drástico y tal vez
el trabajo híbrido no está muerto pero
definitivamente está enfermo y es un
término que hemos trillado y la verdad
no nos hemos sentado a analizar cuáles
son sus verdaderas implicaciones en la
experiencia humana
la productividad de los equipos y de las
personas trabajando desde la casa podrá
hacer seguir siendo bastante alta pero
otras problemáticas como el aislamiento
también muestran cifras muy preocupantes
los datos demuestran que nos sentimos
aislados
desconectados y muchas veces con falta
de motivación y esto solo resalta un
hecho definitivamente previo a la
pandemia nosotros no íbamos a la oficina
simplemente a ser productivos sino que
íbamos para conectar con las personas
ahora mismo es un gran momento para
dejar de pensar solamente en maneras de
cómo hacer híbrida nuestra productividad
y más bien enfocarnos en cómo lograr
llegar a ese balance que haga que
nuestros espacios de trabajo funcionen
en beneficio mutuo para nuestra vida
personal y laboral
hoy en día las empresas y organizaciones
tienen un gran reto el de convertirse en
ese lugar al que las personas de verdad
aman ir como por ejemplo cuando uno
elige ir a trabajar desde su cafetería o
restaurante favorito convertirse en ese
lugar que de verdad las personas se
apasionan por ir y haber no les voy a
mentir sin duda alguna es maravilloso el
también tener la posibilidad de trabajar
desde algún lugar remoto pero es igual
de maravilloso encontrar esos lugares
donde nos sentimos conectados y donde
nos sentimos parte de una comunidad
debemos empezar a imaginar un futuro
donde el trabajo gire alrededor de la
libertad de elegir y empezar a construir
un presente adaptado adecuadamente
los espacios de oficina pueden estar
viviendo una de las revoluciones más
grandes que hemos visto en los últimos
años pero definitivamente cuatro puntos
esenciales que las empresas más
innovadoras que mencioné al inicio están
aplicando para cambiar su futuro
los roles de las oficinas y el trabajo
evolucionaron para siempre pero
definitivamente la oficina sigue siendo
el mejor lugar para conectar a las
personas en especial aquellos que
dependen de una colaboración cara a cara
proyectos como campari en nueva york
donde la oficina sea del espacio central
a un gran bar donde los colaboradores
pueden reunirse y tener momentos de
interacción legítima es un gran ejemplo
de cómo podemos empezar a pensar en
espacios de verdadera conexión humana y
olvidarnos de la típica y aburrida sala
de reuniones y es que que más
maravilloso que un espacio donde las
personas puedan de verdad vivir la marca
que representan día a día y dar paso a
interacciones laborales reales y
espontáneas
la cultura la comunidad y la
colaboración son el centro de la nueva
experiencia de trabajo el nuevo rol de
la oficina es celebrar la comunidad y
enaltecer el sentido de pertenencia
proyectos como planes en londres
demuestran que el futuro de los espacios
de trabajo se va a enfocar más que todo
en brindar experiencias no solo a sus
colaboradores sino también a sus
visitantes la incorporación de
amenidades que permitan una colaboración
ágil y sin barreras va a ser
determinante para la búsqueda y
retención de talento en el futuro y es
que definitivamente los espacios de
trabajo son un claro reflejo de la
cultura de cada organización
las tendencias que veníamos viendo se
aceleraron la incorporación del
bienestar la salud y la hospitalidad se
han vuelto el foco del cambio como
pueden ver en las imágenes la oficina ya
no se ve ni se siente como una oficina
sino más bien como un punto de encuentro
un punto social por ejemplo este cliente
en san jose costa rica decidió
replantear todos sus espacios
tradicionales e incorporar nuevas
metodologías de trabajo en equipo en
este espacio se brinda una verdadera
experiencia de exploración aquí los
colaboradores cuando eligen ir a la
oficina pueden planear su día basado en
lo que vayan a hacer sus equipos con
paneles móviles y espacios sociales
totalmente reconfigurables los
colaboradores ya no van a la oficina a
trabajar solos en un escritorio sino a
conectar con sus equipos
y por último el punto más importante de
todos la flexibilidad y la adaptabilidad
son cruciales para el futuro de los
espacios de trabajo pero esto solo se da
de la mano de una cultura innovadora y
que promueva la adaptabilidad al cambio
sinde es un gran ejemplo de que esto es
alcanzable en el país mediante encuestas
virtuales aún así durante la pandemia se
logró crear un espacio totalmente
flexible donde no existen escritorios
asignados sino más bien una serie de
espacios reconfigurables para el trabajo
grupal
además sinde decidió alejarse de los
suburbios demostrando que las oficinas
también pueden ser un centro de
integración social y urbano a ese
networks en escazú es otro gran ejemplo
de que cualquier espacio acompañado de
una cultura innovadora puede convertirse
en un centro de creatividad cuando un
colaborador decide ir a este espacio no
encuentra el tradicional espacio de
recepción sino más bien una serie de
mobiliarios reconfigurables salas que se
pueden reconfigurar para las diferentes
actividades
además si se decidió olvidarse del
tradicional escritorio y simplemente
dejar una gran mesa central donde los
equipos pueden colaborar sin barreras
el futuro de los espacios de trabajo más
allá de si son remotos o presenciales se
va a enfocar en crear sitios donde el
talento y la creatividad puedan
converger para florecer en nuevas ideas
sin fronteras los invito a resetear esa
idea de que el trabajo es algo que
simplemente se puede adaptar a un modelo
híbrido no y más bien dar paso a un
modelo enfocado en la experiencia social
y emocional un espacio de trabajo que
esté enfocado en mejorar nuestra
experiencia humana y sobre todo un
modelo de trabajo verdaderamente
humanizado muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]